Before we dig into
the camera perspective,
viewport awesomeness that is the rest of
this lesson, let's learn one more shape.
The shape renderer can make for us.
Circles.
Also partial circle or arcs.
We're going to explore more
code in the course repository.
You can load up this project
yourself and follow along.
To dig in, let's check out the TODOs.
Here's the most basic circle you can
draw, specifying the x position of
the center, the y position of the
center, and the radius of the circle.
And there we go, it's beautiful, right?
We can also draw a partial circle or an
arc, by specifying the number of degrees
counter-clockwise from the positive
x-axis that the arc should start And
how many more degrees it should
keep going from that point.
So this line is 45 degrees
from the positive x-axis in
the counter clockwise direction.
And then 270 degrees is three
quarters of a circle, so
we get this Pac-Man shape.
Circles have a dirty
little secret though.
They're not really circles, they're
a fan of triangles where all their
triangles have their points
at the center of the circle.
ShapeRenderer will pick how
many triangles to use so
the circle looks smooth.
But if you make super small circles,
it might choose to use too few.
This optional last parameter sets
the number of segments to use.
Let's see what happens when we
set the segment count too low.
If we set the segment count too low,
we end up with a circle that
looks like a stop sign.
This can also happen if you're
drawing very small circles but
you're zoomed way in on them.
Circles can be drawn using either
ShapeType filled or ShapeType line.
The ladder draws just
the outline of the circle.
If we want to draw
both solid circles and
the outlines of circles in
the same render callback,
we first need to end our filled batch
and begin a new batch in line mode.
let's give this a try.
There we go, a circle drawn in line
mode is just the outline of the circle.
let's try something crazy and
draw some target rings.
Bam, there we go.
We can also draw just the outline
of an arc just like so.
And if we draw the outlines of a bunch
of arcs stacked up on top of each other,
we can draw some funky
snail shell like thing.
Remember, if any of this seemed
too complicated or went too fast,
don't just take my word for it.
You've got all this code sitting on
your computer so check it out and
play with it yourself.